-Tuesday is Deep Dish Pizza Day.
-FLEMING: Yay!
Yeah, or as New Yorkers call it,
Casserole That Can Go
(Bleep) Itself Day.
(laughter)
Uh, personally, I do enjoy deep
dish. I like both, all right?
I am bi when it comes to pizza.
Uh, I like the thin,
but I like the deep dish,
'cause it's one of the few foods
that's classified
both a carbohydrate
and as an intense sedative.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
And no one... no one likes
deep dish pizza more than
Pizza Squirrel!
-(applause and cheering)
-FLEMING: Yeah! Oh!
It only took him 25 minutes
to climb up that tree...
-(laughter)
-(Hardwick pants deeply)
...where he had
a massive heart attack.
(panting loudly)
The only reason
I think that's funny is just
that when he falls out
of the tree,
having had
a massive heart attack,
is the tiny little squirrel
ambulance that pulls up.
And they run out.
(in high-pitched voice):
Clear!
Don't you (bleep)
die on me! Clear!
-Playing the...
-BRAUNGER: But then they can't
fit him into the truck.
HARDWICK:
They can't fit him into the...
-(laughter)
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
Comedians, what's a fun fact
about Pizza Squirrel?
Emily.
He's going through a real messy
divorce with Pizza Rat.
HARDWICK:
Yeah. Points. Points.
-Jon. -Well, he stores his nuts
in Papa John's hole.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
He does.
Matt Braunger.
He's knowingly
lactose intolerant.
His family hates him
for his heinous farts.
HARDWICK:
Yeah, points. Points.
No, but they're adorable
squirrel farts.
-They're adorable. -BRAUNGER:
They are. They sound cute, but
-they smell like gas. -HARDWICK:
Squeaky... Yeah. Yeah.